I'm Nick Gillespie for reason all over
Washington DC politicians of both
parties are celebrating their recent
election victories secure in another
term that will last 24 even six years
not enough politicians are crying please
help us make more politicians weep
reason has been helping to make
politicians cry since nineteen sixty
eight our hardcore libertarian
journalism policy analysis and
commentary exposes government waste
fraud and corruption with your
tax-deductible donation to our efforts
we can make even more politicians cry on
an almost daily basis for one hundred
dollars a year far less than the central
kitsap wastewater treatment facility
methane recapture improvements in
Washington state will be able to ferret
out and publicize more instances of
government overreach eleven times a year
we'll send you new issues of our
award-winning print magazine and on a
daily basis at reason calm and reason TV
will release stinging new critiques of
abuse of power you'll also receive one
of six reason books and a tshirt of your
choosing please give now because not
enough politicians are crying
you